hey what's up guys my name is clinton
jones and i've been creating
viral action comedy vfx based
short films on youtube for the last 10
years
and i've had the pleasure to work with
some of the most creative
talented and downright passionate groups
of filmmakers on the internet and even
though
some of them just love chucking
dodgeballs at my head at full blast
ren dude i still love you man so to paul
matthias and rick over max on you guys
have been incredibly supportive of my
passion over the last two
years so it truly is an honor to be
presenting on behalf of maxon today
and to you guys at home thank you so
much for spending the next hour with me
and if you guys enjoy the next hour then
head on over to my youtube channel where
i live stream
cinema 4d knowledge for you guys every
single saturday
so the big question how do you make a cg
element look indistinguishable from the
real thing
right and once you've modeled and
textured something that looks legit
how do you integrate it into your live
action footage
so over the next 50 minutes i'm going to
walk you guys through my process when
tasked with adding a photoreal cg
element to
your live action plate and we'll get
started with shooting your footage
so you want to have a plan in mind when
capturing your live action plate what
are you adding to your footage
how big is it will it move around or is
it going to be static
will any real shadows pass over your cg
element
or will the fake shadows interact with
anything else besides the ground
are there enough natural tracking points
in your scene or do you need to throw
some down
the more specific you can be with what
you're shooting the less headache you're
gonna have to go through in the post
process
and once you've decided what to shoot
there's a couple camera settings you
need to keep in mind
frame rate aperture shutter speed focal
length those are a couple things right
so
generally a higher shutter speed a
higher aperture and a smoother camera
move
make for an easier track so the more you
shoot and track footage
the more liberties you can take while
filming just know that the time spent
tracking may double triple quadruple you
know it all depends on the shot so don't
go too insane
you know right out the gates once i've
shot my footage you'll want to capture
some sort of
real world reference even if it's just
me standing there
reference provides us with a number of
real world truths we can use to guide
our cg elements towards that photo
realism we're all shooting for
so if you guys want to get really really
fancy alright you're going to want to
capture a custom
hdri and this is definitely a step not
to be missed if you have the opportunity
to do so
it allows us to actually light our cg
object with the real environment we shot
our footage in
and it also ensures that our reflections
will reflect that same environment
and is achieved by capturing a series of
bracketed images of your environment
from a tripod that will later be
stitched together into one 32-bit
high dynamic range image and if you guys
want to know how to create your own
custom
hdr images there's a link to my youtube
channel in the description
and you guys can follow the exact
process that i use so i'm inside of
cinema 4d
r22 this is a brand new blank
slate blank scene here it should look
pretty familiar to you guys
if not no worries let's start motion
tracking our footage
if you look to the top right cinema 4d
actually comes with some really
handy layouts if you hold this down and
you go down to motion tracker
it's going to present you with a new
layout that's totally optimized
for 3d tracking it's really really nice
you'll see here if you double click to
create a motion tracker object we'll do
that
and you're presented with some new
options down here right we can load our
footage in
we have the 2d tracking tab you can do
automatic or manual
tracking and the 3d solve which turns
your 2d points into 3d points
and creates a virtual camera for you so
we'll want to go to footage here
and load in our footage you can do that
by clicking this button here or
you can just double click up here we'll
select our shot
and it's loaded in it's going to play a
little chunky because we hadn't actually
cached any of these frames
so if you look down on the bottom right
scroll down just a bit you can see our
footage was loaded here
the dimensions of our footage uh 3840 by
2160
now it's down sampled to 640 by 360. and
usually
you want to track footage that isn't too
low res here this is a little too low
res for us i think so if you go to
resampling
you can actually go say fifty percent
and that'll down sample it to nineteen
twenty by ten
eighty we wanna cache these frames so
the easiest way to do that is just hit
play
and the first pass through going to be a
little chunky a little laggy
that's because it's caching these frames
down here
great so now our frames are cached and
we're able to actually play back our
footage
so we know this is a solid
representation of our footage because we
can see our frames per second down here
and if you guys want to see this
in your hud you can actually hit alt v
and right over here in the hud tab you
can just check your frames per second
along with some other really
handy check boxes here like total
objects total points and you'll see
those
up here in the top left so the tracking
process
always begins with a 2d track and the
way this works is basically
depending on how these 2d points move
around
in space right depending on the
foreground the foreground's going to
move different from the background
the mid-ground will move a little bit
differently then it'll take those points
and convert it into a 3d solve
so we're going to auto track this
because the auto tracker is actually
really really nice
so basically the way this works you can
either track backwards
you can track forwards or you can track
in both directions at the same time
and that's what we'll use for this shot
here we'll auto track it
the create auto tracks that's useful
when you have
like a feature that comes in from frame
right and then
you're panning across it leaves frame
left and you never see that again
you just want to scrub through your
footage and create auto tracks
all the way through and that helps the
tracking process but for our case
we're good with auto track so let's just
auto track this scene
and if you look down here we can see
cinema 4d thinking real hard
your program's not frozen it's just
thinking and there you go
if we scrub to the beginning we can see
we have a healthy amount of tracks at
the beginning of our footage
right in the middle we have a whole
bunch and towards the end
there's still a healthy amount to make
this a little easier to see right
because these points i mean honestly i'm
colorblind just straight up
so it is hard to see these points down
here so what i'll do is i'll go to
options
and track display we can just turn that
to show tracks only
still hard for me to see this though so
we'll go back to
footage and i'll take the brightness
down to like 30 percent
then i can see these points so much
better and some of them are clicking in
and out that's okay
they're going to hang on for dear life
for as long as they can but the ones
that are
sliding around like let's see if we can
find one that slides
like this guy right here and this is
also another really cool
thing that cinema does here is you have
this tracker view
and you can scrub through and see where
things gets off you can see it slide
right there
oop no good that one's got a mind of its
own
let's delete it boom gone so once you've
scrubbed through your footage and
are happy with all of your 2d points
here again it doesn't need to be
exactly perfect you'll be here till next
christmas doing this
you can actually just navigate over to
the 3d solve button here
and you're presented with a couple more
options so the solve mode
full 3d reconstruction this is basically
like a
free move as in our camera is moving
freely through 3d space like in real
life you know
a nodal pan is a special type of track
and that is a track
that takes place when you have a camera
on a tripod
and it's just panning or tilting around
your scene
that's when you'll want to switch it to
a nodal pan planar track is just another
type of
special tracking mode but we're going to
do a full 3d reconstruction
and here is a spot where we can plug in
a known truth our focal length we'll set
that to known
and constant our focal length i know i
shot
on a 24 and your sensor size
you can actually google your camera and
its sensor size and it'll tell you
my camera it's the sony a7r ii and i
believe the sensor size is 35.9
but i'm just going to leave that at 36
it should be fine now all we have to do
here
is run the 3d solver and you'll see it
thinking down here in the bottom left
you know give it a minute or two
and the solve is finished if we click
off of the motion tracker we should see
all of these green and red points in our
scene let's scrub through and make sure
things look great
sure enough it looks like they do so
obviously our position
and rotation is way off and i'm betting
our scale is off as well
so the next thing we need to do here to
make the rest of this process
super easy on us is normalize our scene
we want to get to the point where we can
spawn a figure and when we hop into the
camera
it's sitting right in the middle right
on the origin it's scaled properly and
it's
oriented properly so with the motion
tracker selected
we're presented with a new option here
if we hold this down
we have three options we're able to
adjust the position
and we can actually select which axis is
which axis that way cinema 4d
knows which way is up down left and
right so we'll start with a position
constraint and that's basically
allowing us to choose the origin point
the 0 0
0. so i'm just going to scrub forward
and i'm going to select this point
right here and you'll see this new
constraint was created
and the mode by default is set to
feature to position that means the
feature or the 2d point
goes to a position of 0 0 0.
so if i click away that figure we
created is now
sitting right at the origin point which
is exactly what we want this is going to
make things super easy on us
when we're going and placing a new
newspaper stand that we're going to
model in a second
but obviously the orientation is off so
we need to set that next
so let's select the motion tracker and
hold down the constraint button
and we'll create a vector constraint
okay
so we want to find two points that are
on a certain axis in our case let's find
the x-axis that's going from left to
right
now we could choose these points here
basically any two points that are on a
specific axis are fair game
so i'll select this one here select this
one here and it's going to create this
line
and over to the right we are asked a
couple questions here
so we'll want to take this axis and
define it as the x-axis
so if we click away now we can see our
figure is lined up almost
it we just need to determine a z-axis or
a y-axis
let's go back to the motion tracker and
we're going to make another
vector constraint one two
let's hop over to axis and say that is
the z-axis
and now when we click away it's
basically perfect
we just need to mess with the scale but
that looks
solid to me so the reason i like using a
figure
is it gives me a really good sense of
scale you know this comes in
at just under 2 meters i'm 5'9 so this
thing is probably just as tall as me
and this actually allows us to reference
the footage of me walking into place
here
and seeing how tall i am and we'll just
walk it in by eye
let's select the x-axis constraint that
we created
and we'll go to length here we'll say we
know it
and i'm just gonna guess here that from
here to here
is i don't know three feet and now the
size looks locked in
just fidget with that number until the
scale looks right for you
so once i've 3d tracked my footage the
next thing i want to do is set up my
lighting
so that whenever we bring in assets or
in our case
when we model a newspaper stand things
are just looking good by default
so you ever see those guys on set with
like
a reflective chrome ball and then they
have like a matte gray ball
and ever wonder what they're doing with
those well basically they're capturing
real world reference and if you can
recreate that real world reference
in 3d then that means your lighting is
basically good to go
so we're going to do that here in cinema
4d we can hop back out of this layout
and let's go ahead and hide these auto
features we can hide our figure
and i'm just going to hold down this
cube here we'll spawn a sphere
and let's go up to 100 segments
and we'll give it a radius of i don't
know 1.5
feet and we'll raise it off the ground
by 1.5 feet
so it's just sitting perfectly on the
ground there and i use
octane as my renderer of choice but you
guys can follow along
all the same tips and tricks apply like
if you're using redshift
and i'll actually briefly break down
some of the redshift equivalents before
we composite in after effects
let's just go ahead and make a new
octane glossy material and drop it onto
our sphere
and let me load up another layout i have
where you guys can actually see what's
going on here
let's render the scene and right now
we're just getting
this image here so let's go ahead
into our material we'll go to index and
we'll set the index to one
that's going to turn it into a perfect
chrome ball nothing's changed here
because we don't have an environment
that this sphere is reflecting so let's
go ahead and load in an environment here
i'll load in an octane sky and we'll go
ahead and grab
our custom hdri image that we made and
now it's actually reflecting
that image so what we'll want to do is
compare the reflection of our hdr
environment here
with a animated jpeg sequence of our
background
so we can double click down here in the
material window
and we'll double click that new c4d
material under the color tab here i'm
just going to drop down this arrow
and load up the jpeg sequence of our
footage that i exported from after
effects
so we need to make a couple tweaks to
get this jpeg sequence
to actually play in our viewport so
first i'm going to go to the floor
button
we'll make a background and we'll drop
that new material onto our background
and you can see actually that it's in
our live viewer
but it's not in the viewport and the
reason it's not in the viewport is
because the octane sky is blocking our
view of that so if we just hide the
octane sky
now we can actually see our background
loaded in and if we
scrub through here it doesn't work it's
not a jpeg sequence it's just one frame
so what we need to do is actually click
this little icon here
and it's going to bring up this new
window let's click animation up here at
the top
and down at the bottom only when you
click calculate will it recognize your
material as
a jpeg sequence and if your numbers look
all
crazy like mine you just need to make
sure that you set your start frame to
zero
inside of the composition settings in
after effects before you render
and we should be able to scrub through
here and see our jpeg sequence
and it actually shows up here in the
live viewer as well
so by default we can see that our hdri
image is too saturated and too contrasty
so we'll need to adjust that i'll click
on the environment tag here give us a
little bit of room we'll scroll down
and we'll click this button here and
that takes us to node view
i'm going to scroll down grab the color
correction node
drop it right in between and from here
we can actually start
adjusting some of these values to better
match our hdr environment
to our live action plate so let's do
saturation point
eight and i'll just render region here
let's take the gamma point eight as well
it's a little bright so we can take the
brightness
down to 0.6 maybe
0.7 and we're getting pretty close i
still feel like it's a little saturated
and that looks like a match the last
thing we need to do is just adjust its
rotation
and i'll throw a uv transform on this
guy
and i'll just scroll this around until
we're looking at this back wall
because that's what's behind me filming
right if i go over to direct lighting
you can see we're looking
in the correct direction down the street
so the last thing we need to do
to set up our lighting is create a sun
and a ground plane where the shadow can
be cast
across the ground so i'm going to hop
back into
camera view here i'm going to go ahead
and lock the scene
we'll set this to 0.2 so we can see
what's going on
let's create a plane and i'm just going
to hit
t and make sure i'm in model mode here
and we'll scale it up
and i'll create an octane diffuse
material go to common
and check the shadow catcher option
we'll go ahead and drop that onto the
plane
and we can see here it's catching our
shadow if i hide the background you can
see here that we're just rendering our
element and the shadow
usually i'll take the plane and i'll
hide it in the viewport just so it's a
little easier to see
so the last thing we'll need to do to
set up our lighting is to create a sun
so i'll make an octane daylight here if
you guys are using octane you can go to
objects lights octane daylight
and now we want to just line up our
sunlight
with the actual direction of the sun in
our hdri environment
so i'm going to hop out of camera view
here
and let's look at a lower view
we need to hide our plane from the
renderer
and let's switch over to direct lighting
if we hit the daylight tag and scroll
down
there's a little check box here mix sky
texture we'll check that
it's going to take the directional light
from the sun but it's also going to fill
in the environment
with our custom hdri so you're getting
the best of both worlds
so this line is pointing in the
direction of the sun so if i hit
r and rotate this
let's bring our plane back in we can
kind of see what's going on here
and if i hit w that'll switch my octane
daylight
gizmo from local to world space and now
we can just orient it around like this
now we need to make sure it's coming
from the right
position so if we navigate around and we
see the sun
is coming from that point there's our
octane sun
so in world orientation i'm just going
to orient it around
so that it perfectly matches so if we go
to our color correction node
by clicking this image we can take the
brightness all the way down
and just get a better idea of where our
sun is at
so that we can walk it into place here
and now it's perfectly lined up with the
hdri
environment so let's bring
this back up to 0.7 and hop into camera
view
alright so now that our lighting is all
set up we can drop in anything here
and it's automatically just going to
look nice the shadow's a little dark but
we'll deal with that in after effects
okay so now it's time to finally
model a newspaper stand so we can drop
it into our motion track
scene before we do that though i just
want to set up a quick layout with you
guys with some custom buttons
so we can make the modeling and workflow
process a lot smoother
and a lot faster here inside of cinema
4d there's a couple ways you can do this
you can just
hit shift c and look up anything you
want here in our case let's try the
center axis tool
and all you have to do is click and drag
and you'll see this little gray strip
let go and there it is the other way
is you can go up to window customization
customize commands
and do the same thing you can just type
out whatever you want let's try
the transfer tool
and that transfers one model to another
makes it really easy to move things
around another one of my go
to's would be set selection and that
basically allows us to select a number
of points polygons or edges
and make certain tweaks to just those
areas
another classic i always go back to is
the axis center tool
it basically allows you to move the
pivot point anywhere around your model
and the last thing is reset psr
that's position scale rotation and
that'll just snap anything you have
selected to the origin
now if we close out of cinema these
buttons will disappear
so what we'll have to do is go to window
customization
save layout as you can name it whatever
whatever you want you know some custom
thing
or you can go and save it as your
startup layout
so that every time you boot cinema you
have these buttons ready to go
so when modeling i will always use
reference and this will actually carry
into the texturing phase too
you want to be able to reference the
real world thing rather than just
guessing you know what you think it
looks like and that is actually going to
take our our vfx shot our model to the
next
level because i think the average person
can tell when something just doesn't
look right if something just doesn't
function you know
so always use reference photography
when creating stuff from scratch here
and when you begin the modeling process
you never want to dive right into the
details
you'll want to start by blocking out
your model with primitives first
so i'll spawn a cube here and i'll
actually spawn a figure
so we know the size we're working with
we know that the top of it comes about
up to the belly button so i'm just going
to take this cube hit t
and scale this thing down and i'm going
to start with the
base here so let's scale it down you
know something like this
and i think in this case we can just hit
c to make it editable
and now here is a great little tip you
can see that the anchor point is right
in the middle
of this cube right but we want the
anchor point to be at the bottom so
that's why we have this handy tool here
the axis center tool we're going to take
the y axis and we're going to slide it
all the way down to the furthest point
on the bottom here so it's negative y
we'll hit execute and you're going to
see that anchor point just snap right to
the bottom
that way when you're in model mode you
can just set y
to zero and you know it's going to be
sitting right
on the floor if you hold down control
with this object selected with any
object selected
you'll spawn your new primitive right in
the place
of the primitive that you had selected
or the object you had selected
so i'm just gonna hit w to get my move
tool going here
right so using the reference
imagery i know that the body of this
thing is a little bit
longer on the x-axis than it is
on the z-axis right and i'm going to
make this
cube editable by hitting c another thing
here guys you really
want to learn your shortcuts the more
shortcuts you know
the faster you'll be able to work in
cinema i always think of it as like
you know you start a new program and you
can barely crawl
you're just laying down on the ground
but eventually you'll start crawling
then you'll start walking
you'll start jogging eventually you get
to the point where you can run
you can jump really high and then you
can fly and you want to get to the point
where you can fly around in this program
and learning your shortcuts is
definitely a great way to do that i'd
say it's mandatory
so i'm going to hit k and you see l for
loop path cut i'm going to hit l
i'll make sure my sure i'm in edge mode
here and i just want to make a cut here
because again we're just going off of
the reference we'll grab this top point
and you can see how the anchor point is
skewed at this 45 degree angle that's
because it is set to
local orientation if i hit w that's
going to cycle back
to world orientation so let's slide this
back about right here
and i know there's like a little
offshoot hanging from the side out
over here so i'll actually go to polygon
mode and i want to break this piece
off just this top piece so the shortcut
for that is
u p and that's a shortcut for split
we're going to break it up all right so
we have that piece i'm going to grab
this edge
slide it out just a little bit i'm going
to make a cut here
and i'll make a cut here so that we can
delete this polygon
and now we have our entire top piece
right here
so let's go ahead and hide the main body
i'm going to go to edge mode and ul is a
shortcut for a loop selection so that's
going to get the surrounding edges of
this whole thing
if i hit w and i hold ctrl i can make
some new faces here just by clicking and
dragging down and this is basically
going to be
our topper now we'll bring in our main
body again
and orbit around here um so it has
some lips on the side here if i go to
the main body
and we'll go to edge mode we'll hit kl
again that's
a loop path cut let's do one there
let's do one here we'll go on the other
side as well now we could do
uh like a symmetry setup but honestly
this is just going to go by
so fast i don't think it's going to be
necessary okay we're going to grab
all four of these corners here i'm
holding shift to select
everything and then i want to extrude
these out so the shortcut for extrude
is m t so we'll zoom in
extrude those out so we have like a nice
little lip there
that's great and the top has the same
deal
so we're going to do ul for loop path
selection
and mt for extrude and just
bring that out a little bit further so
it just hangs
over the edge of this thing now the last
main chunk is this little door here
where you open it up
and get inside for the newspaper so
let's select our main body
holding control we're going to spawn a
cube right at its center point i'm going
to hit t for scale
and just drag this down okay i'm going
to hit w
bring the cube out hit r for rotation
and rotate this let's go into a side
view here
this will work just perfect i'm going to
make this cube editable
select these points move them down and
you'll notice
it only selected one of the points
right so this this is not correct so
we'll undo that
and we'll want to make sure that with
our selection tool selected only select
visible elements
is unchecked it's going to get
everything it's just going to laser
through it
and we'll just bring this down so it
lines right up
back in let's select this face here mw
for extrude inner
and that comes in just a little bit here
and then mt once again for extrude we'll
just pull
this back and just make sure this lines
up
flush with the edges of this newspaper
stance i'm going to hit t
for scale and just open this up so it
reaches the bounds
of the newspaper stand so this is
basically the idea you just want to
block this thing out so that we can get
a general idea
of what we're going for that way we're
not wasting time we want to be as
efficient as possible
with our work so i'm going to take this
and let's go ahead and move it into our
motion track scene to make sure our
scale is right
we can select all this drop it into the
null
call my stuff geometry i'm just going to
copy it window over
and move it over to our motion track
scene i'm just going to paste that in
there and it looks
a little small so i've pulled some
points around to match our model to the
actual
newspaper stand from this point we'll
want to start detailing our model which
we don't have all the time for today
but i want to show you guys two last
modeling tips starting with the bevel
modifier
now if you mouse over to the modifier
button we can hold this down
and we're presented with a list of all
the modifiers
we'll click the bevel modifier and we'll
make it a child
of our geometry and by default it's
looking janky so let's adjust this thing
but it is cool how the use angle button
is checked by default in r22 usually
that'd be unchecked and it'd be beveling
everything even the stuff you don't want
beveled like
this line here but with the use angle
checkbox
it knows hey you know we just want to
bevel certain parts of the geometry
rather than parts you know you probably
don't want beveled
so the offset is what controls the
amount of bevel i'll come in here and
just go
point one and that's nice that actually
gives us a nice bevel
and it's a really good tip to bevel all
of your edges because there's no such
thing
as a perfect 90 degree sharp edge and
when we bevel our edges
the light catches nicely on the sides
and that is definitely something you
want to keep in mind when going for
that photorealistic look and we can set
the subdivisions to something like
three you can do five you know whatever
you guys feel like is right for this
thing
and you can always adjust this later
that's the beauty of the bevel modifier
is you're not baking in any geometry
this stuff is completely editable if you
get notes from a client you're going to
want to be able to adjust this stuff on
the fly and when you bake things in
you're kind of screwed you have to do it
over and another thing i like about the
bevel modifier
is the selection box so let's go ahead
and select all of our outermost edges
that we want beveled
and we'll set a selection so we made
that button
our custom button for set selection or
you can go to select
and come on down to set selection and
you can see right next to our model here
in the objects window
we have this new icon and it is the edge
selection
tag here okay so what we'll do is we'll
go to our bevel
and we'll drag that edge selection tag
into
the selection and it's just going to
bevel
that little bit there now what i like
doing is doubling up on this
so let's just set our offset to 0.5 but
we still want a bevel on these edges too
so let's go ahead and up the
subdivisions heck we'll go to 10
and i'm gonna control drag the bevel so
it duplicates it
and it's going to look all weird but
let's go ahead and delete
the edge selection and let's readjust
point
one and it's getting everything
so i think the hierarchy matters here
let's move this bevel
on top and now you can see we have full
control
over the bevels that we have on our
model we're getting different kind of
bevels
and they're completely adjustable so
definitely use these bevel modifiers
when you can it's going to save you a
lot of time
you're going to be able to change things
on the fly and you're going to be able
to have full control
over your edges okay and for the last
bit
of modeling tips for you guys i just
wanted to quickly talk about
the volume modeling method here we have
the volume mesher
and we have the volume builder so since
our newspaper stand has a ton of screws
holding it together i've set up this
small
scene just as an example to get us
started
it's just a sphere set to hemisphere and
a cube extruded out to this plus shape
which we'll use to cut into this
hemisphere
so if we drop both of these objects into
the volume builder it's going to look
like this
16-bit old video game kind of style look
in here
what we want to do is grab the volume
builder and we want our cube on top
we want to subtract it but it still
looks wonky right let's take our voxel
size
to 0.5 inches
let's zoom in here we can see that it's
hollow
and that's not good so we'll grab our
sphere let's turn
off the volume builder for a second and
we want to just close this hole
so i'm going to go to polygon mode right
click and we will close
polygon hole md for the shortcut there
and i'm always trying to come up with
dumb ways to remember that md's like a
doctor they're patching holes
and you will hopefully never forget
the shortcut for the closed polygon hole
tool ever again
uh the cheesier the better with those
usually works out
so let's bring that back in and now you
can see we got a nice little cut here
now obviously that is super low poly
now the best way to fix that if we go to
sphere i'm going to hold alt and drop a
subdivision service
by holding alt you are making the object
you have selected
an automatic child of that new thing
that you have created
hopefully that makes sense for you guys
um shift is the opposite it'll make it
apparent
okay so we want to still subtract
wrong thing we just gotta get our order
right again boom and now
it's looking a little bit better if we
take our volume builder
hold alt once again and we'll drop it
into a volume measure
it's gonna take our volume and actually
turn it into polygons that we can use
we can hit n a to change our shading
method now we can see
a little bit of those polygons in here
signal shift and drop in a smoothing
modifier and that can just smooth things
out just right
and that about wraps up the modeling
section of this presentation
i hope you guys can use those tools to
speed up your workflow
and give you guys more possibilities in
your modeling process
generally the more detailed you guys can
get when it comes to modeling
the better and the closer you can get to
the way something is actually built
the better and it all depends on how
close your model is
to the camera if it's way in the
background then it can just be a block
out kind of a quick sketch
type thing but if it's up close you're
going to want to get real detailed with
it
because that detail goes a really long
way and the same is true for texturing
so let's talk about
how to texture something and make it
look legit and the first thing i'll do
is look at my reference material and see
how this thing actually looks let's take
a look at the attributes here now
there's inconsistencies in the color
there's dark parts
there's red parts there's parts where
it's like
kind of orangish and reddish there's
definitely variation in all of that
there's some dirt on this thing
there is some variation in the way the
paint builds up
on this um there's dirt on the glass
the top of this thing is broken up in a
really interesting way
some parts are really rough some parts
are a bit more shiny but i'm betting
there's some fingerprints on this glass
and if we zoom in here there's
definitely some bump
on the top of this thing i know the top
of this is warped a bit
we have scratches in the top of this
there are surface
imperfections all across this newspaper
stand
and that is one of the crucial steps not
to be missed when going for that photo
real look
is surface imperfections nothing is
perfect guys like look at all the
smudges on this glass how many times
it's been wiped how many times it's
been cleaned and then it's got dirty
again there's a bunch of
rain residue built up on this thing
there's some grunge on
this sign the list goes on and on and
you don't want to miss out on these
surface imperfections
they'll make your object look used and
really tell a visual story
so what we're going to do is just build
up a base material for
this newspaper stand we're going to go
over color we're going to get bump we're
going to get some normal in there we're
gonna get some service imperfections and
i'll just walk you guys through my
process
of how i do that so i'm gonna begin by
lining up my camera
to a nice position where the sun is
bouncing off the top
of this newspaper stand that way we can
actually see how the reflections and all
the roughness is working
and i'm going to make a new octane
glossy material
you can do that by just going to
materials octane glossy material or once
again you can hit
shift c and search literally anything
inside of cinema 4d let's hop on in
and i'm going to apply this new material
to
the top of our newspaper stand now the
first thing we're going to do is work
out of the diffuse channel
i'm going to grab an rgb spectrum and
let's pipe that into the diffuse
and we'll pick like a nice blue color
here
now we want to break up the
color that we see here in the reference
there's
points where we have darker red we have
like some brighter red going on you know
it looks like kind of like an orange
so i'm going to control drag that rgb
spectrum let's pipe that new one in
it should look exactly the same and
let's just go ahead and change this a
little bit
not too crazy probably go a little
darker maybe a little less saturated
and that should be good now we want to
go ahead and mix these two colors
together
using a noise node so i'll drag this out
and let's go ahead and pipe our noise
into the diffuse so we can see
what's going on here now it's a little
bit difficult to see
so i'm going to right click this solo
the node and we can see it a lot better
the the mapping is a little bit off so
i'm going to make a projection node here
and i'll set that to xyz to uvw and
that's going to wrap around
this geometry really well
i'll go to the contrast and i always max
it out just so i can see what's going on
now we want to mix these two colors
together
using a mix node so i'll pull that out
we'll go texture 1 texture 2 pipe that
into the diffuse
and if we disable solo by default it's
just setting it up so that it's 50
50 the amount is set to 0.5 but we want
to use
this noise node to break up
these two colors so i'm going to pipe
the noise into the amount
they're actually very very similar so
let's go brighter on one
and there you go you can see how the
noise node is breaking up
these two color nodes okay from this
point what i'll do is probably up the
octaves
let's try eight and it's just gonna make
this a bit more detailed we'll go a mega
.8 and it's going to break this up in a
more interesting way
and obviously the contrast is way too
intense so i'll just set that to five
and this is looking a little too milky a
little too
cloudy for me so let's just adjust
our colors a little bit
and that is a very very subtle
difference in the colors here
i want to scale this up though i want to
scale the noise up so i'm going to
select the noise
make a uv transform i'll right click it
solo it so we can see what's going on
and i'll take the transform up to
2 and that's feeling a little bit
better there so now we have some nice
inconsistency
uh it's very subtle but i promise it'll
pay off in our color channel there okay
and you can right click the mix texture
and
auto arrange selected it's a really nice
way to clean that up
next we'll focus on the roughness and
the roughness controls
how how the reflections kind of bounce
off of this
material here if i line this up at an
angle where you can see
it's basically like an iphone screen
right now but if i crank this roughness
up
it really spreads out the reflection
and what we're going for is something
along these lines where parts of it feel
wet and more reflective and the other
parts are more
rough and the reflection is spread out
we're going to do
a very similar trick here we can use a
noise node to do
just that and i'm going to pipe this
projection node
into our new noise node and let's just
pipe that into
roughness we'll right click we'll solo
it so we can see what's going on
and i'm going to boost the contrast up
to 5
and for this i'm probably going to up
the omega
to one and the octaves let's just try
10 we'll try turbulence maybe
circular i think circular could be nice
let's just
up the contrast so it's too bright we'll
bring the gamma down
or up rather so we can get something a
little bit more
broken up like this so let's see what
that looks like
awesome so you can see how the noise
node broke up our roughness channel here
some parts of the surface are rough and
others are more reflective
and you can take this and i'm going to
make a new transform node
we'll scale it up let's go 2.5
and it's a little intense right now so i
want to bring down
the contrast just so it's broken up in a
little bit
of a different way here and it's still
looking a little cloudy so we can come
in here and adjust
the gamma a little bit more and that is
actually feeling
pretty nice to me i know that this metal
is warped a little bit because when i
look back at the footage i can see the
reflections kind of bouncing over
these like little hilly parts of the
metal
so we'll actually do that with a noise
node once again and we'll pipe it into
the bump channel
so i'll select both the transform and
the noise control drag
and pipe that into the bump and you're
definitely going to want to grab your
projection
and pipe that in as well okay so right
now
it's too granular it's too fine we need
to
take the contrast to
zero and i'm feeling like let's just
reset
our gamma we'll go 2.2 the omega
we need to smooth this stuff out so
let's go 0.2 and octaves
will go to we can set this back to like
per lens something like this is what
we're going for we want these nice
large rolling reflections
so let's disable that and
we can actually compare and store our
render buffer
right so we have one side frozen one
side live
now if you guys want to go to the max
here and really have more control
over the power of all of your image
inputs here
what we can do is grab out a multiply
pipe it right in there
we can grab a float and
pipe that in and float is basically just
a number you can type in which by
default is set to 0.5
but let's say we go to like five and
then it'll take whatever is in the bump
channel and crank it up in our case
by 10 times obviously that's too much
i don't think we need that setup we can
just keep that at one
but it's a nice trick to know when it
comes to having more control over
your image textures here now as far as
scratches go and inconsistencies in the
paint build up
let's talk about the paint build up
first so i'm actually going to use a
normal map to control the
inconsistencies in the paint buildup
i'm just going to drag this in this is
from mega scans gotta love them
all right and we're gonna just gonna put
this into the normal channel if we zoom
in we can actually see some really
intricate detail here in the paint it
looks like it's actually kind of painted
on here
now the last things as far as texturing
goes for this demonstration
is scratches and this can really really
make
your texture shine and it's probably my
favorite part of the whole process
we're actually going to mix two textures
together
in order to achieve that scratched look
basically
you have your painted metal here and
then it's scratched away and eroded away
to see this nasty old rust but i want to
do it with an
actual kind of like shiny metal more so
like this
these little details here on the side so
to do that let's briefly make
the shiny metal material we'll do that
by making a new
glossy material in octane we'll double
click and we'll go down to the index
set that to 1 and just like the chrome
ball you know that's going to turn it
into a chrome material here so we'll
apply it to the top and you can see
sure enough it's a chrono material we
want to mix these two together
with a mixed material and octane so
let's give ourselves some room
and we can see here that it's looking
for material one and material two
so i'm going to drag the glossy material
the chrome material
into material one and we'll drag our
paint material into material two
okay so let's double click and go into
the mix material
hop into node editor if you guys aren't
using the node editor at this point
definitely try and get here because you
can actually see all the stuff that's
going
into your material it's very very
helpful
and you know this this kind of setup
here it's a little
messy but you can always right click
stuff and just clean things
up with the auto arrange selected
feature it's really really nice
okay so we basically have our chrome
material here
and our paint material right here
and it's mixing between these two
once again by default with a float
texture set to 0.5
and let's apply the mix material to our
geometry
so right here we have a fantastic
scratched surface imperfection that
we're going to use
to mix between the chrome and the paint
let's bring this in
let's get rid of this float texture and
let's pipe this into the amount
let's right-click it first we'll go to
solo node to see what's going on
and we always want to give it a
projection node and reset that to box
and let's go ahead and give it a uv
transform
so that we can scale it up and down i
think we can take this
and work the gamma so that more
of the scratch texture comes through
and there we go when you drop the gamma
down you can really see
that material come through and that
looks super awesome
so definitely don't miss out on the
surface imperfections because they're
going to get you closer to that photo
reel look
there's definitely no such thing as a
perfectly clean
object you know unless you're doing like
product photography or something
but that's just a whole nother game so
before we render you'll just want to
duplicate your texture
change some attributes and texture up
the rest of your model
and before you render this thing out you
always want to check your source footage
for motion blur and make sure you match
it in your render i usually like to
render my motion blur outside of cinema
4d just because uh
you get those true highlights
maintaining their full light values
across
the motion blur streak and if you guys
aren't rendering as
image sequences here you definitely want
to make sure you do that it's kind of a
built-in
redundancy it's going to make sure that
if your computer crashes or whatever
you have those backup images and you'll
just start it from the next image you
left off on
so under save i will just go to open exr
usually
16 or 32 bit should be fine and make
sure you have alpha channel checked
so when you drop this in it's going to
be super nice and easy to composite all
right so as promised i'm gonna walk you
guys through the redshift equivalence
of all the different octane nodes that i
was using it's very very simple
and i'm very new to redshift but i
picked this up pretty quick so i think
you guys can
as well if you create a redshift
material
right i already have one made i'm going
to double click and go into the shader
graph so the first thing you notice
if you're familiar with xpresso the
redshift shader graph looks
very very similar in fact it's basically
the same thing
and let's just take this piece by piece
and break down this very simple texture
uh just like octane i dragged and
dropped my image textures
into this window and that's all of these
yellow nodes here you got your
your ambient occlusion your albedo
roughness specular normal
displacement all that good stuff um
pretty simple right
now over to the left here you can type
in anything you want and it's going to
search through
this node list for example i used a ramp
which is the same thing as a gradient or
levels if you're in photoshop or after
effects and you can just type that in
here
and drag it out right and you're just
going to pipe your
nodes into each other just like this and
you can edit your attributes here on the
right side again very very similar to
octane
all the same techniques apply across the
board let's say you want to drop the
brightness value of your texture
let's try a color correct node that's
what i have right here and all you're
going to do is just
maybe drop your level scale and it's
gonna adjust
the brightness of your diffuse map or
whatever
you want to apply this color correct
node to and very similar to octane when
you're piping in your displacement
you're going to want to use a
displacement node as well so you would
just come into
the search bar here type displacement
grab your displacement node
pipe that in and you'd pipe that into
the output you're just going to drag
this node right up into here
and boom displacement it's already set
and you're good to go
and the same is true for normal in
redshift you'll want to use
a bump map and use that as your input
straight into your bump input on your
redshift material
and for this very simple render all i'm
doing is lighting it with
a redshift dome light and that's going
to allow us to pipe in an hdri
image right here inside of general you
just you know find your hdri
load it right in lastly let's just talk
about a shadow catcher and how easy that
is inside of redshift
you can see i have a shadow catcher set
up and it's actually really cool all you
want to do in redshift is just
give your object a a redshift object tag
here
you'll go to matte you'll override
you'll enable in general you'll scroll
down and enable
your shadow and your shadow catcher is
all set
so it's actually very simple guys all of
the same tips and tools and techniques
across the board apply for all the
different renderers so whatever i'm
doing in octane
you guys can do in redshift as well no
problem okay guys and now for the fun
part this is when
we're going to bring everything together
we're going to go inside of after
effects and we're going to composite
this thing we're going to match
the shadows the highlights we're going
to match those mid-tones we're going to
get the hue saturation we're going to
add some grain
and really make this thing feel like it
fits inside of our live action plate
so let's double click in the project
window here to load up our image
sequence
and navigating to any one of these v2
images you will make sure that our open
xr sequence box is checked
and that's just going to ensure that it
brings in all the frames here
i'm going to double click and grab a v3
as well i rendered one
out with no glass and we'll composite
those together
let's go ahead and drag in our footage
and we note that it's shot at 23.976
we can right click our image sequence go
to interpret footage
and main and double check that this is
indeed
set to 23.976
so let's drag that in and
our footage is 4k the render is 1080.
i'm just going to hit shift
f and that's going to fit it to the
composition
but if you notice there is this white
halo
around our render and that's caused by
just
the way after effects is looking at the
alpha here so
we'll want to go back to interpret
footage and change the alpha to straight
on matted and you can see that line just
go away so that's
a thing that i always do when bringing
in renders from cinema 4d
i'll drop in our no glass render and you
guys should see here
that it's just looking straight through
to the street
the reason i did that is because for
some reason um our specular material
is acting like a mirror and we don't
want to do that so we want to have full
control
over the opacity of that reflection and
all we need to do is have
our other render at the bottom and then
work the opacity just so
it matches our reference footage and now
we can select both of these we can hit
ctrl shift c
to pre-compose these two image sequences
together we'll move all attributes
and hit ok all right our track looks
super solid here we definitely need to
composite this
render the lighting is a little intense
the saturation is a bit intense
and the shadow is too dark so how do we
know exactly what values we need to hit
other than eyeballing it
so if we go up to this little window
here the info
panel on the top right you can see hsb
for hue
saturation and brightness we also have
alpha
and if we reference over the the actual
newspaper stand we can see
that the saturation and brightness are
sitting right around
46 47 kind of area so we can compare
that to our render
which is definitely not hitting those
numbers
and we want to adjust it so that those
numbers match
the first thing we'll do is adjust the
saturation so let's just find hue and
saturation
drag it on there so this saturation is
at 47.48
our saturation is at 70. so let's try
negative
30 a little bit
further and that feels about right to me
now the biggest thing is the
black levels here we can see that the
black levels on our render are way
darker
than the actual source footage so let's
go ahead and grab
some levels and i'll actually move the
hue and saturation
below the levels so we'll do this level
adjustment first
and i'm just going to crank this slider
until this is looking right the
brightness
is 10 11 on this
and it's about 10 on hours so i'd say
that matches
in terms of the brightness of our actual
newspaper stand that's at 59
this is at 48 so let's just bring this
slider down
and now the highlights can be a little
intense as well so we'll want to check
those highlights too
so we're going to want to bring this
down until we get that to like a 70.
yeah that's
that's not bad at all so this feels
pretty good to me minus the shadow
it feels a little bit dark and actually
this is
not quite fully opaque so we can go to
our alpha settings here
and adjust these
and just give our shadow a little bit
more brightness here two last things we
can do here to make this render really
shine and blend into our footage
let's take a look at these shadows and
you can see this noise
specifically in the shadows of our live
action plate here now if we go to our
render
we can see that it's just perfectly
smooth there's no noise at all we can
just search for noise and
drop that into our render give it
something
like three percent maybe five percent
you always want to add noise always
always match the noise you can do that
with a match green effect as well but
it's a lot more render intensive and
finally there is a
super subtle slight bloom in the
highlights
in footage it's not super apparent here
but when the sun is striking something
pretty harshly it definitely kind of
washes out and diffuses out
the highlights and you can replicate
that in your render
by duplicating it throwing an extract
filter on it
and we'll just work this bottom slider
let's actually solo it
so we're getting rid of everything
except for the highlights
so right around here it's just the
newspaper and at a certain point the top
of our newspaper stand when it's getting
hit by the sun
and we can work the bottom slider just
to kind of feather
that out and if we bring everything back
in
we can set this to something like screen
and throw a fast blur on it and we drop
the opacity down to
something like 15 and it's so subtle but
these effects will go such a long way
and really help blend in your cg
elements to your live action plates
all right guys so that was a lot over
the last 55 minutes so we talked about
shooting your footage and what to watch
out for we brought it into cinema 4d and
we tracked it we talked about different
ways to get nice tracks out of c4d
we then lit our scene using an hdri
and we combined it with a sun alright
from that point you set up your shadow
catcher
and then you're good to start modeling
or dropping in your cg objects
so we started modeling with a block out
always start with a block out because it
saves us a lot of time
then you go into detail all right once
you have your model we're going to
texture it
we talked about surface imperfections
and how important those are to making
your model
look photo real before you render make
sure you match your motion blur to
your plate always render your motion
blur outside of cinema 4d because you
get those real nice highlights
and from that point we talked about
compositing inside
of after effects so guys i really hope
you enjoyed this last hour thank you so
much for taking
the time out of your morning to spend it
with myself thank you to maxon for
allowing me to present here at seagraph
and if you guys
enjoyed this then please head on over to
my youtube channel youtube.com
punisher i'm getting into cinema 4d i'm
getting into after effects and i'm
getting into
unreal engine so come on over and let's
get learning together
thank you guys peace